this is a historic on this day you
became the first world leader to
recognize Israel's sovereignty over
areas in Judea and Samaria that are
vital to our security and central to our
heritage the soaring music and
off-camera voiceover had all the
hallmarks of a campaign video promising
Israeli sovereignty in the occupied West
Bank but for Benjamin Netanyahu a day
after what he had termed a
history-making event in Washington the
brakes have been at least momentarily
applied he had promised to hold a vote
in cabinet on Sunday on annexing the
Jordan Valley and illegal Israeli
settlements in the occupied West Bank
but the United States is now making it
clear that it wants further coordination
before the process begins
so does this hamper Netanyahu's election
campaign one former Israeli diplomat
thinks not Trump fainting for the
difficult work he did in creating this
plan so little you know is behind it so
if there is another move with which they
can help him be quiet let my government
do it we even have an overwhelming
majority but Netanyahu isn't the only
one trying to make electoral capital out
of the announcement his Defense Minister
the head of a rival right-wing grouping
of parties said annexation had to happen
now not after the election I've ordered
the formation of a special team to
implement the application of Israeli law
and sovereignty on all Jewish
settlements in the Samaria Judea the
Jordan Valley and the northern Dead Sea
the team will start working immediately
while the Israeli left has rejected the
plan Netanyahu's main centrist
challenger Benny Gant's has endorsed it
but it does risk shifting his campaign
away from its previous focus on
Netanyahu's indictment in three
corruption cases this plan coming just
after the official announcement that his
his and diamonds have been farmed with
the Jerusalem district court means that
he will he now has hold of the of the
agenda of the narrative and it's
certainly something that he'll want to
continue to push the consequences of
this deal with its provisions for
Israeli annexation for the literal
walling off of any future Palestinian
state from the heart of East
rue salam could be felt for years but
here in the midst of yet another Israeli
election campaign the timeline being
focused on is much shorter the next
thirty two days until Israelis go to the
polls
again 'harry force at Al Jazeera West
Jerusalem